je vous l'avais promis il est là il est
avec nous et on est très très content de
l'avoir à nous présenter en exclusivité
son nouveau titre on va jouer avec lui
applaudissements pour jimmie foxx
m
on salue le black avait manqué mon bel
animateur à la peau d'ébène
bonjour fêtards ne va pas plus coûteuse
alors écoutez nous allons jouer tous
ensemble ce soir on va démarrer des
missions en fanfare en feu d'artifice
d'accord je vous présente pineau la race
raquette avec moi bonjour sinon c'est
bien petit échauffement dégueulasse aile
droite et de gauche
mais ce chaton ou alors je vais vous
faire deviner des personnalités bien sûr
jouer chez nous des personnalités de la
télé bien sûr personnalités de tous les
horizons corps et personnalités que vous
aimez d'autres que vous nous donnez
n'aimait pas mais ce n'est pas grave
l'essentiel c'est de jouer ensemble
un beau black au monde jibril alors
allez on y va on démarre tout de suite
avec une position du pipi dans le tgv
pour démarrer
j'en fais là la position du pq dans le
paisible dans l'avion bien sûr oui un
peu plus comme ça mais attention les
chaussures on y va musique / une polka
voici la première questions du quiz de
jimmy foxtrot
bonsoir c'est un chanteur folk à bôle
cas bolt à paule ka il à perdre et les
nac du connemara ou la java de broadway
entre chats il a les cheveux tu oublies
et il a fait tellement de lifting que
maintenant il a des poils de cul qui lui
poussent sur les jours tino horning il
ne sourit jamais d'ailleurs on se
demande s'il a vraiment aidé en toi qui
pue
allez pour à 50 dans les points dont il
faut noter c'est isabelle morini-bosc
michel sardou bonne à jouer
je l'avais deuxième personnage position
de william leymergie pour démarrer donné
par ici musique voici la 12e édition du
quiz de dhimmi d'osterode bonsoir c'est
un animateur télé mundo chihuahua il est
d'origine égyptienne comme omar sharif
obama j'habitais
et je serai appelé maggie elle voit
souvent rouge avec et savent où ils
animent tout le monde veut prendre sa
place sur france 2 sont de l'or
quant à jimmy
cette rapide n'a ni toit
dès qu'il aura problème winona troisième
merci saab a été très troublé par cette
danse gym et fox fait avec non merci
d'être avec nous
merci merci ta gueule merci merci mois
et comprend ce qu'on prend au doigt et à
l'oeil comme ça oui au doigt et à l'oeil
surtout au doigt oui parce que je
pensais dans un match où on aura
baptiste giabiconi j sera avec nous on
va parler
politique de l'extrême spécial obesity
vous allez me dire ce que vous en avez
pensé vous réagissent également beaucoup
1 sur twitter sur jean-michel en tee
shirt et tout le monde dit alors sur
twitter et sur facebook
c'est clair on trouve je vous jure joly
on trouve que jean michel est
dégueulasse en tissu c'est vraiment ce
combat c'est la fée je vous jure que je
ne mens pas comment vous le trouvez vous
jimmy et gallas merci alors dit mieux on
va jouer vous nous fait découvrir des
personnalités bien entendu on reçoit
aussi beaucoup de gens qui nous disent
on est fan de jimi foxtrot vraiment on
adore on veut qu'il est toujours là
quand même norme il a détourné tous les
jours dans tous les ordres à calais il
reçoit à venir tout le temps et sur la
côte d'opale osé je sais alors nous
continuons donc le cuir et le cuit avec
une position alors vous allez c'est de
trouver la personne qui position de j'ai
perdu la petite vis de mon meuble ikea
les musiques musiques
voici la troisième question du quiz de
tiny foxtrot toi il présente le journal
sur tranche de salsa merengue il a la
même coupe de cheveux que le playmobil
qui fait des travaux tir à l'arc
il peut faire aucun manège au parc
astérix et sur sa photo d'identité
on le voit tout entier johnny clegg
johnny clegg
et si tu changes trois lettres dans son
nous ça fait bizarre au pluriel
flashdance
isabelle duboscq était impérative que tu
parles est il
oh